It's a sort of Mount Everest Question that
you just want to solve because . . . The discovery
is a major breakthrough on a subject that
has bedeviled mathematicians since ancient
times . . . This new result by Yitang Zhang,
which says that there are actually infinitely
many pairs of primes, which are separated
by no more than about 70 million.
News started spreading through Twitter that
some mathematician had proved that prime gaps
were bounded.
So when I saw that I was immediately interested,
and I started calling up some mathematicians
and saying, "Is this real?
Who is this person?"
Never heard of him.
Absolutely never heard of him, and when I
heard a rumor about that it was possible that
this was done and roughly what techniques
were used, I said there's no way somebody
I've never heard of had done this.
I mean really unusual to have someone like
sort of outside the math world or just on
the fringe of it, just come up with this kind
of result.
And he basically seems pretty normal.
I really believe that mathematics should be
very pure.
I love math.
No one taught me but myself.
I like to read to learn and to think.
Although we say that mathematics should be
logical — of course it is logical — but
at the very beginning you are thinking.
You are feeling.
This seems very unclear, then you try to make
it clearer and clearer again.
That could be intuition.
Intuition is sometimes hard to describe
by words.